Not wanting to put a damper
on Rhea's celebrations
or anything, but it's time
we killed her dead.
Smash her skull in with a rock.
-Nice!
-KENDALL ROY: Okay.
Way to ease us in, sis.
Will there be nibbles at this
event? I was expecting nibbles.
What I'm thinking is,
we just-- we tell him direct.
We just tell him, all of us,
we won't have it.
-Should I maybe take the floor?
-SHIV ROY: Okay.
Would Rhea really be
the worst thing in the world?
Or does a woman from outside
actually make sense right now?
(SCOFFS) Okay, right, well,
she-- she got to you.
No. Just, I'm fighting
on two fronts,
and I may have to make
a request to Dad
about a bridge situation,
and she's been understanding.
This is bullshit.
Ken?
-Well...
-Well? Oh, come on.
Oh, she-- You're backing
her too, rebounder?
No, I-- I just...
I just think that maybe you've
overplayed your hand.
Excuse me?
How did she get to you?
Oh, you think that you'll
be given another shot,
at some point, ever?
No.
-And Roman, you? No.
-Uh, well, I mean...
No, she thinks you're a dipshit,
or maybe you're just
too much of a fucking dipshit
to see that.
Fuck you. I know more
about this business than you.
More than any of you, actually.
Roman, no one gives a fuck
about management training.
Dad does, Gerri does.
It's corporate daycare.
-(MIMICS SHIV)
-(KENDALL LAUGHS)
That's not a good retort.
Don't fucking laugh at that.
-Shiv...
-Thanks for taking this
seriously.
-I do.
-It's just... it's transparent.
-Uh?
-KENDALL: You know...
...Rhea's who Dad wants,
clearly.
-So--
-But he's wrong.
-Yeah, but--
-In case you want it in writing.
Maybe, you know,
you should just like--
like, give it up.
Full disclosure,
I'm starting to like her.
Aww, he likes her!
Yeah, this is why you don't
hatch a plan with Connor,
the first fucking pancake.
First pancake. Okay, thank you.
You're a brat.
You know, none of you
have been through
what I've been through,
so just--
Aww, my mommy got sent
to the booby hatch
and now I'm sad.
Fuck off.
Think you're being too emotional
about this whole thing.
Oh, my fucking God!
Are you doing the emotional card
on me?
-Fuck's sake.
-I mean...
I mean I was gonna mansplain
it to you,
but I think he did
a very good job.